early to bed and early to rise makes a
man healthy wealthy and
wise many of life's failures are people
who did not realize how close they were
to success when they gave
up if a man empties his purse into his
head no one can take it from
him by failing to
prepare you are preparing to
fail luck is the dividend of
sweat the more you sweat the luckier you
get what we do during our working hours
determines what we
have what we do in our Leisure
Hours determines what we
are beware of little
expenses a small leak will sink a great
ship failure is only the opportunity
more
intelligently to begin
again never let your failures go to your
he or your successes go to your
head success is
99%
failure it has been my observation that
most people get ahead during the time
that others
waste weak desire brings weak result
results just as a small fire makes a
small amount of
heat when everything seems to be going
against you remember that the airplane
takes off Against the Wind not with
it in times of great stress or
adversity it's always best to keep busy
to plot your anger and your energy into
something
positive do your duty and a little more
and the future will take care of
itself second is the first of the
[Music]
losers thinking is the hardest work
there is which is probably the reason so
so few engage in
it a goal is a dream with a
deadline do not look for approval except
for the consciousness of doing your
best a friendship founded on business is
better than a business founded on
friendship
there is no other quality so essential
to success of any kind as the quality of
perseverance it overcomes almost
everything even
nature I would rather earn 1% off 100
people's efforts than 100% of my own
efforts Vision will without execution is
just
hallucination whatever the mind can
conceive and believe it can
achieve if you can dream it you can do
it nothing is particularly hard if you
divide it into small
jobs
if you always do what you've always done
you'll always get what you've always
got set your mind on a definitive goal
and observe how quickly the world stands
aside to let you
pass you become what you think
about don't be afraid to give up the
good to go for the
great the first step towards getting
somewhere is to decide that you are not
going to stay where you
are the secret to success is to do the
common things uncommonly
well success is getting what you want
happiness is wanting what you
get the only real mistake is the one
from which we learn
nothing there are things money can't buy
and hard work can't
win one of them is
happiness obstacles are those frightful
things you see when you take your eyes
off your
goals if you can't do great
things do small things in a great
way the first man gets the
oyster the second man gets the
shell quality means doing it right when
no one is
looking a quitter never wins and a
winner never
quits one of the greatest discoveries a
person makes one of their great
surprises is to find they can do what
they were afraid they couldn't
do there is no man living who isn't
capable of of doing more than he thinks
he can
do givers have to set limits because
takers rarely
do our only limitations are those we set
up in our own
minds if you do not conquer self you
will be conquered by
self
change before you have
to if you want to succeed you should
strike out on New Paths rather than
travel the worn Paths of accepted
success success comes from keeping the
ears open and the mouth
closed people who are unable able to
motivate themselves must be content with
mediocrity no matter how impressive
their other
talents if you would know the value of
money go and try to borrow
some a man who acquires the ability to
take full possession of his own mind may
take possession of anything else to
which he is justly
entitled he that cannot reason is a
fool he that will not is a
bigot he that dare not is a
slave anyone who stops learning is old
whether at 20 or
80 anyone who keeps learning stays
young don't find fault find a remedy
anybody can
[Music]
complain most people spend more time and
energy going around problems than in
trying to solve
them there is no disgrace in honest
failure there is disgrace and fearing to
fail when your desires are strong enough
you will appear to possess superhuman
powers to
[Music]
achieve the man who does more than he is
paid for will soon be paid for more than
he
does by what thou Hast no need of and
air long Thou shalt sell thy
Necessities there are three Faithful
Friends an old wife an old dog and ready
money laziness travels so slowly that
poverty soon overtakes
him quiet people rarely become rich
because you make money by talking to
others so start
talking don't work after 50 because
money won't let you know yourself spend
time wisely then you will be
[Music]
extended people become poor in old age
because in their youth they fail to
appreciate the power of saving and
investing the best remedy is to seize
every chance for financial growth even
later in life by Saving and investing
wisely the best way to become poor is
finding a job that will suck the life
out of
you rich people avoid two things in life
stupid company and stupid
spending an investment in knowledge pays
the best
interest the fastest way to double your
money is to fold them in half and put
them in your
pocket one today is worth two
tomorrows rather go to bed without inner
than to rise in
debt